okay so distance a what is it one my kid
on my mobile right one like guys come on
what kind of triangle is this it's just
that it's just a it's just the writing
your triangle here right a and that's be
right okay that's fine all right well
what do I do with this where do I go
with that now what a suggestion was
perpendicular distance formula okay how
would I use it how they go about using
it pisses up this is the perpendicular
mrs. formula just don't forget that the
a's of b's and c's here I'm not the A's
and B's that we have here but that's the
general tone what am I going to do with
it what would I want my in creature
okay all right so I know what this
distance is ok so i can i can pop that
in ok and then on the right-hand side
let's see this ends being the sea where
are they going to come from they
correspond to the coefficients don't
there ah yes I have to put in general
for i guess but i could get that let it
be fine ok and then i'll try and solve
ok now can anyone see there's going to
be a problem as i as i do this right
this is fine the age square gonna be
spread and even see are also fine but
there's going to be a serious one can
you and see it i can i can come up with
different letters to account for them I
mean we could we can call them different
things so that they don't overlap let's
assume we get our labeling right and
then don't clash is it there's a problem
solving issue here um there's a problem
with this method can he was here now
should I will complicate things but
thankfully because I know where
everything is I can say what's going to
be I can know what's to be positive what
to be negative so I should be able to
get rid of a whole on cases that way
okay let me ask you a question how many
variables am I solving for when I get
this equation in the right form happy
early I'm solving for three variables
all right the x and the y this is what
I'm expecting for X and this is what I'm
expecting for y how many equations do I
have to solve for these two very I've
just got that that's all I got shall I
mean trouble I can get down to something
simple but I will not get just one
answer now what's the need something
else to help you okay what am I bishop
now I'm going to let you file that away
for a second part of the problem is our
choice of the way you'd go about this
the perpendicular distance formula is
just complicated okay and it's got X and
I built it to it already okay so what
I'm gonna do is I'll just um leave this
offensive side and suggest another way
that we could use this the distance and
this the under for the equation of the
line to find out these boots are now
first you know pilot polar you guys keep
saying is I just stop this here then I
put it in and just start working with it
okay that's a natural instinct to have
but I can't do it right because I don't
know that's the case here however
I can give it some name and then I can
start working with it even if I don't
know exactly what it is okay so i'm
looking for an x-coordinate in a
y-coordinate I've got a whole bunch
exports of my clothes right so certain i
might add videos i'm going to call it X
D and why do so these what I want to try
to fun okay now the reason why this is
useful to me is because now I can I can
take this equation and I can sub some
things into it right because that set of
coordinates or to satisfy this equation
yeah okay so should be always say this
okay yeah
is the equation of de the savers the
equation of a be okay sort of but be
careful okay because this distance that
you've got here is off at an angle right
but the distance if you want to add if
you want to have like a vertical shift
you need to know that distances right so
I guess I'll be plus plus baby you have
to show that right I have to establish
what this distance is you can do that in
a variety of ways I'm doing one of them
right so I see what you're getting we're
just we're still we're still trying to
use information we haven't proven yet
all right now
okay now I've got these statements here
right what I'm really trying to link is
distance ain't gradient those are the
keys ok so here even though what you've
got is equation of the line I think it'd
be nice if I just get an equation with
remaining X of the and why because then
I can eliminate one of them ok so if i
rearrange us a little bit i think
probably a nice helpful way to ride
would be like this i think i've just put
that around yep good now the reason why
this is gonna be helpful for me is
because this guy will appear in a second
just watchful here ok where's it going
to appear this is my distance a be
justin.tv but i know it's the same as
another distance which one DB that's the
one I'm after right so i can say
distance be d is equal to the square
root of a squared plus B squared but I
know another way to find the distance of
BD right what is it it's just from here
to here and I know those two points
right so what's going to be here on the
left-hand side well it's X x2 minus x1
+ + y2 minus y1 squared yeah Pythagoras
so I'm going to have to which place we
gonna match up x minus x 1 x 2 square
plus y 2 minus y 1 square that ok can
you see where i got those two points
from that's VFD that's equal to this ok
can you see what's about to happen can
you see what I'm about to substitute ok
see that XD minus B that's right there I
knew it was coming because when I was
going to work out this distance you're
going to have to subtract busy escorts
somehow ok so now if i substitute that
out and this I'll be lazy I want to
square both sides at the same time ok so
I'm gonna have this yd was sorry why do
the four squared that's that
substitution there plus that zero
disappears now I have this okay it looks
messy that's not that bad is it what
should you do what step would you do
next what I call okay when we try to get
out of this equation yd right there why
cordon so what should I do I should
factorize right because that's going to
be the quickest way to make yd the
subject yeah so what should I factorize
out I can read it twice right why this
weird so why do squared okay what am I
going to be left with a squared on B
squared plus 1 yeah is that okay all
right kick that guy of your side
okay now I'll run out of space here what
would you do here though is this
quickest way to get out of this say
again it yep perfect that'll get rid of
these if i multiplied by B squared here
in here B squared B squared multiply
multiply okay that's going to simplify
this fraction down the bottom right so
I'm going to get yd or squared I'll
leave that there for a second now what
happens to the bottom a squared + B
squared becomes a squared and the one
becomes you swear sorry boss cancel
cancel okay now what be careful
why
good so they're both square so I have to
set solutions right what do you say next
I think your logic was exactly right and
your answer was wrong so hold on a
second we established earlier B is
negative B is negative but why he is
above the axis so that's positive right
so i would say i probably say both of
those okay therefore contrary to normal
right the answer we're going to exclude
is the positive one I think that's what
you meant to say to me to minus 90
alright done there we go there's the y
value that was the hard part how am I
going to get the Eternity where where am
I going to put it into what's the best
place probably this one yeah I probably
should have named that earlier so that I
could have said yup so now let's come
back to it okay substitute into one
what are we going to have XD minus B
equals minus B times a 1 B get this guy
over and these two cancel and I'm home
happy with that now you can apply the
same logic and you'll get the next part
before I move on to Part C and Part D
what was the other way we said we're
gonna do it without other alternative
yes you do a triangle okay now i'm not
going to UM rehearse it fully because
take two lines right but let me show you
how it work and you decide which one is
better I'm kind of in two minds this is
a little more difficult algebraically
it's kind of like multiple times I
looked at you and you're like I don't
know what to do next okay but writing
out of the geometry if you're going to
try and stuff you're gonna have to prove
comrades you know just going to have a
lot of words right so if you're okay
with riding on that and you want more
straightforward logically proof then go
that way here's how I would do it I need
to make a triangle over here okay so i'm
going to say let point p be the point on
the x-axis directly beneath thee yet you
have to make a new triangles on
once you've got point P there if you
name some of your angles over here so
for instance let a be h equal thinner
that's the that's mighty what's this
going to be 90 minus theta okay but
again you can't just write all of these
numbers and you actually have to save
wise you have to set angles on a
straight line add up to okay if that's
90 minus theta what sits up in the
corner you know okay so now you've got
angle angle angle angle side side so you
can prove Congress once you prove
congruence you can say well look this
site is side B what does it correspond
to it has a day pd so you can say that's
be but you have to be careful because
you have to explain why actually the
corner week writing speed because again
B is negative okay and you can exactly
the same logic you can say look this
corresponds to this side so that's a and
the x coordinate of this is really the
whole lot if this be and this is a
pleas- and the whole thing should be
negative to select the access that's
where you get your favourite a fool
okay so that went quickly because I just
said it instead of riding it okay but I
wrote them down I read the boat down
right okay so they're from there's my
diagram I suppose that takes up a lot of
space all the way up to here okay so
it's basically a full page that's how
long it takes you to explain the
geometry to do with this triangle and
you can compare that to from here that's
my second proof so they're too probably
shouldn't staple detail after here so
it's about the same length it's just not
as worthy okay so if you prefer the
algebra and you don't just hate geometry
reasoning to death then this way that
I've showed you is probably the way to
go any questions exactly okay now the
rest of the question I think falls out
relatively easy after that that's why
there are far less marks to do with it
ok Part B we have to find the corner of
F in terms of an T which is exactly the
same process so in many ways from
testimony and then from there part a how
do you share the things that concurrent
what do you think the best way to do it
yeah
yeah so in fact parts putsy it CMD CMD
you have to find this equation that
bring online and that one after you know
those equations right especially since
you already know in advance where
they're going to conquer is on the
y-axis right so you've got a nice easy
value to subia namely x equals 0 right
so sub it in for all three of the lines
only two of them because H is the y-axis
and you're sure that they all pass
through this one point in the corners
crazy